welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul and this video are
breaking down Ahsoka episode 7.
the penultimate entry has just dropped
and throughout this video we're gonna be
going through the Easter eggs hidden
details and things you might have missed
in it we'll also be giving our theories
for next time and make sure you
subscribe and logged in so you don't
miss our finale video now last week saw
thrawn's return with Morgan and Co
finally reaching paridia but while this
yeah Dave filoni spent six weeks
building up to this to explain his
reveal when if it was me I would have
just said somehow thrawn returned and
just left it at that great writing that
would have been air but showing off his
brand new night Troopers and my main man
Enoch we watched as he rallied his
forces together to return to the main
Galaxy after giving Sabine Ezra's last
location we watched as she traveled out
into the Wilderness and came across some
naughties before they led her to Ezra's
Camp all on her tail were balen and
Shane with a pair being ordered to kill
them both and wipe Ezra out once and for
all we closed out with a circle almost
arriving and with that recap out the way
you should be up to speed so sit back
look at that like button and described
with prejudice
now we begin back in the old Galaxy at
the new Republic Center which is rocking
a new republic symbol right on the front
during Mando season 3 we saw a similar
sort of building that Carson tiva
visited which had a banner instead of
etched into it this cements in the
Republic are now fully integrated
whereas that felt more like it had been
hastily thrown up later on they
mentioned the conflict on Mandalore
placing this firmly after the events of
Mando season 3. nowhere has been
court-martialed and like they say this
is no longer still a rebellion feels a
bit weird seeing hero without goggles in
live action but I you know what kind did
they get I also think Admiral Akbar
could be there and we get a little smirk
from on Mothman due to her rebellious
attitude she herself was quite the rebel
during the Andor days and she's
definitely the one out of the council
that is on Hera's side now the
debriefing is said to be like a child's
fairy tale but we of course know that
the stories of paradia would tell like
this to the Younglings in the Jedi
Temple Lucas actually wanted Star Wars
to seem like a fairy tale which is why
every movie started with a long time ago
in a galaxy far far away last week
played into that heavily and it further
carries for this fairy tale aesthetic at
the last second Hera is saved by C3PO
who brings forth a data disc like the
one in A New Hope with the Death Star
plans on it it's a big big Cameo let's
go and we learn that this comes directly
from Leia Leia eventually ended up
breaking off from the new Republic
during the sequel Trilogy and we can
kind of see the reasons why she left
here she says she sanctioned the mission
to cite us and thus Hera is allowed to
go free a huge announce to Simon a
Berman on Twitter for pawning out that's
Senator giono is disrespectful of droids
like many after the Clone Wars he still
had a lot of prejudice towards them and
I do kind of get the feeling that he's
clearly hiding something there are
imperial remnants located throughout the
new Republic and him shutting down the
idea this quickly it does kind of tease
that he might be one might be a red
herring but yeah the guy doesn't like
them talking about that now it's always
nice hearing from Anthony Daniels and we
end this happy moment slightly brought
down by the reality that thrawn's
Returns on the horizon now from here we
go to the title sequence and get the
title dreams and Madness I was looking
for a true meaning behind this but
unfortunately the only thing I could
find was a Japanese documentary titled
Kingdom of Dreams and Madness if you
know that drop it below but yeah from
what I can gather it's just a generic
title though I might be making myself
sound stupid here which wouldn't be the
first time now we could have the Pergo
moving through hyperspace and see a
Circa on board the T6 training with a
hologram of Anakin in his Clone Wars
uniform Anakin says the line from the
trailer about facing more than just
droids and he then mentions the Ventress
General Grievous and Count Dooku
Ventress is another night sister so
maybe we will see her again in this
night's sister narrative through
Resurrection magic or something else
huge outs to Mt for realizing that
Anakin tells a circle to practice more
than he does because he doesn't need to
practice due to his Heim at a chlorine
count and also his arrogance as well now
Ahsoka it keeps all of Anakin's
recordings in a wooden box on her ship
and I actually think she might give
these to Luke Luke of course only really
knew the character when he was Darth
Vader and though they had that moment at
the end of Return of the Jedi he's never
really seen what his dad was truly like
thus I think handing over these
Holograms it's gonna give a true
perspective of what Anakin was really
like and just bring Luke closer to his
father now you can also catch the little
training droids here one of which look
used in a new Hub when practicing with a
lightsaber on the Falcon the shape in
the design of these somewhat foreshadows
the Minefield which we see later on as
they exit hyperspace now Anakin popping
up again of course has ties to what
happened earlier in the season though
it's to a different medium it reminds us
soccer of her visions and symbolically
riffs on the lessons that she learned
during the Clone Wars I know there's
back and forth still over whether this
was a dream or if it actually happened
but I just don't see how she survived in
the water that long and how else she
would know some of the things Anakin
referenced about his battle with Luke
now her time together in the Clone Wars
is very important for her to have ham at
home so that she can continue to focus
on the good man that he once was balin's
very good at tapping into one's fears
and through the force he's able to send
swap buttons to push in someone to throw
them off their game this is something
that he demonstrate perfectly with
Sabine and using her emotions he was
able to get her to hand over the star
map the sucker as soon as she entered
the area he immediately brought a panic
in which was his way of throwing her off
Anakin spoke highly of you this is why
she ended up lashing out later on and
thus in the will Between Worlds she had
to remember what he was really like
Ahsoka walking away from the Jedi Order
is something she chokes up to being
white Anakin changed but as we know it
wasn't her fault that's the thing this
acts as a reminder of the final lesson
she learned upon meeting with his ghost
which is important for her to bear in
mind going forward into these battles
Simon made a great observation and he
also pointed out that the T6 has
moisture on the Windows this is a great
bit of attention to hell as they're
obviously inside the whale and this
moisture would be coming off of it and
clogging up the glass huyang brings up
the odds which C-3PO of course did
throughout the main trilogy but also
mainly during Empire Strikes Back and
there's more Empire references later on
as we see they've entered a Minefield
upon exiting hyperspace this creates an
asteroid field style Moment Like We also
got in that movie later on they end up
hiding just like how the Falcon did
inside the space Slug and it all kind of
brings this entire thing together I
don't know how they got so many Minds
out there but it's such a tense scene
that throws them immediately into danger
the whales Lee which loses them their
cover and I don't know why pulps didn't
just put but something like this up
around the Death Star or something now
multiple Fighters show up and Asoka
flees into the graveyard Rings outline
the planet going back to the star map we
actually saw a ring of piggle around the
planet on paredia which this of course
ends up representing now this video is
sponsored by ag1 the daily Health habit
that's filled with bitterman's Min
minerals and Whole Food sourced
ingredients so since having the twins
I've been a bit under the weather pretty
much all the time because they keep
going to nursery and bringing back lots
of colds and viruses with them my jobs
obviously very reliant on my voice and
if I've got a blocked nose or a sore
throat it can make the video sound worse
than they already do so I've been
looking for ways to boost my immune
system with a simple supplement that I
can take once a day that's where ag1
comes in and with just one scoop you get
75 vitamins and minerals that replenish
your daily nutrients and leave you
feeling better I used to drink about
three cups of coffee a day now I don't
even bother drinking one because it
helps me feel energized until I go to
bed my immune system is also looking
worse than the emperor after some white
lightning but since starting with ag1
I'm just able to focus on my work and
feel a lot better ag1 gives a
comprehensive nutrition supplement that
provides nutrients for body brain and
gut health in your welcome kit you'll
get an ag1 pouch refillable canister AG
vitamin D3 and K2 ag1 travel pack shaker
bottle and a scoop as well it's so
simple to use and it actually has like a
subtle natural pineapple and vanilla
flavor that I look forward to drinking
every single morning highly recommend
that you check it out yeah just go to
the link in the description make
yourself feel better throughout the day
and just more energized with this daily
Health habit head to my link in the
description below to get a free one-year
supply of AG vitamin D3 plus K2 plus
5ag1 travel packs and your first
purchase of ag1 that's a free one-year
supply of AG vitamin D3 plus K2 plus
5ag1 travel packs with your first
purchase of ag1 thank you again to ag1
for sponsoring this video and I thank
you again for everything you've done for
me now back on the planet we see an
establishing shot with six night sister
statues they're separated into groups of
three possibly alluding to the theme of
trinities that we saw in the star map
room now the great mothers actually pull
a lot from mythology and as we've
learned more about them over the week
it's become very clear what their
Inspirations are the Trinity was first
tend to do us with the three statues
inside the tomb during episode one and
they're clearly based on several
mythological archetypes episode 2 is
called tile in trouble which is a quote
from the three witches that appeared in
Macbeth they're also deathly based on
the sisters of Faith from Greek
mythology with them last week even
bringing up the thread of Destiny
threat of Fate has spoken to us the
thread of Destiny demands it
in the Legends someone's life was
represented by a thread which was seen
as a Lifeline the sisters would often
cut this to kill someone but they could
also use the threat to change someone's
fate if you've ever played God of War 2
on the PlayStation 2 then you know
Kratos was screwed over and his entire
Journey was about getting to the sisters
of Fate so that he could alter the past
upon killing them he took his threat and
pulled in it to rewind time and aspects
like this could have inspired the world
Between Worlds I know this was based on
the wood Between Worlds but yeah lots of
tiny whimey wibbly wobbly stuff that
could have brought this across now the
sisters of Eight's names are clotho
actropo and Lexis which guess what guess
what these three great mothers are also
called as well yep though the spellings
are different their names are actually
the same and his hammers home the idea
that they're based on the sisters of
Fate also shout out to Claudia Black for
playing the main one didn't realize it
was here last week because of all the
makeup but hey good to see her back yeah
she's beating some brilliant stuff on
you always enjoy seeing her pop-up and
stuff now inside we see thrawn
continuing to mount up and get a
hologram message from Enoch these
Holograms appear slightly differently
with it being conjured two night's
sister technology so it looks different
at how the usual ones appear as thrawn
enters we sort of see it forming from
the ceiling and though it was us by it's
such a cool visual how Enoch is somewhat
becoming a stand in farook and it's
possible I could take things in the same
way that they did in the original
Legends run in that thrawn was actually
betrayed by his bodyguard Rook who ended
up stabbing him in the back whilst he
commanded the Chimera not to be like I
think about the Roman Empire once a day
but I did think at the time and this was
similar to several Emperors who were
betrayed by their bodyguards Star Wars
is heavy Roman Empire influences and
even the praetorian gods that we've
encountered pulled directly from the
days of old those were known as the
emperor's bodyguards but they were also
notorious for betraying their bosses and
assassinating them themselves I'm not
sure if they'll go that way with Enoch
or not but his mask is clearly based on
gladiatorial ones the night Troopers
themselves could also be in line with
the ninth Legion which are editor map
pointed out when we were working on our
follow-up Theory video the ninth Legion
was one of the most notorious Roman
forces but they completely disappeared
off the records after 108 A.D what
happened is had historians battle for
Centuries with no one being able to
understand what it was that made them
disappear a story was adapted into the
movie The Eagle though we still don't
know what really went on made up of 5400
they seemingly disappeared on their way
to Caledonia and summer theorized they
got lost in the fogs above Hadrian's
Wall others have said there was a major
Celtic Ambush and this mystery has
fascinated people forever thrawn's
forces of course disappeared into this
other Galaxy with a legion possibly
providing inspiration for what's
happened here now the throne learns
Anakin was ahsoka's Master and they have
lots of ties to each other Anakin was
actually the first person thrawn came
across when entering the main Galaxy and
he was also the one who deduced that
beta was actually Anakin this was
because he realized his characteristics
were the same and this makes the battle
slightly more personal he knows how
dangerous Anakin was though and worries
it might have rubbed off on his
apprentice and empty picked up the line
that this comes from the inquisitorial
database and many inquisitors were
former Jedi so they had lots of
information about the former Jedi Order
now I never really clocked it until
thinking about the colors used in the
episode but I think Osaka becoming a
sucker the why it actually makes her
somewhat a reflection of thrawn her
journey of course was based on ganolf's
journey in Lord of the Rings but we now
have these two sides where both their
leaders are draped in white just
realized that when I thought about how
striking thrawn's uniform was and I
think it really works on a more elevated
level either way we close out with her
hiding in the bones of a dead star whale
which kind of continues the theme of
life and death that Anakin underscored
in episode 5. Mt did a big breakdown
about all the connections between this
and her tail of the Jedi origin story
which itself was titled life and death
brewing a big Deadpool at the moment and
although I really hope a soccer makes it
that alive her death would make a lot of
sense fitting in with the themes of the
season now he cut to a naughty head and
big shout out to Tom on the mic from
Twitter for pawning out the naughty
actually resemble the cellar day from
Star Wars resistance these came from the
planet castilon and much like the Noddy
they were an amphibious species that
tend to live above water a thing like
the howler is that they probably
inspired them in the same way that the
wolves are possibly precursors to the
loud wolves due to peridia being where
the Knight sisters originated from they
might have traveled out into the Galaxy
and have taken some subspecies with them
that then evolved into the others also
it makes me wonder if if the clothes are
just stuck under the shelves or if they
take the shelves off like a backpack get
dressed and then put the shells back on
now speaking of clothes gonna be honest
mate I bloody love getting naughty and
we've even made a naughty inspired
t-shirt just below the video your chimps
want to look good yeah your Chumps want
to get naughty well let's get naughty
with a bloody naughty little t-shirt
goes such a long way to helping support
the channel and as a thank you yeah you
get this cool merch out of it we've also
got our Ahsoka and grago t-shirt Theory
time one and a lot more and they're just
right below the video If you want to get
one for yourself or or a mate that you
want to make look stupid because you
will look stupid wearing that now Sabine
starts to fill Ezra in on the emperor
and he asks if he died she says that's
what people say which might be might be
a little joke on how somehow Palpatine
returned however it may be her tapping
into the force slightly to sense that he
is still out there you also get the
young child Noddy from last week and
this waves to Sabine oh cute he is now
it said that zeb's training recruits and
we of course saw him as a pilot in Mano
season three you also get a better look
at Ezra's scores and this highlights the
conflict that the character's been
through now Sabine talks about the
training but the good times are broken
up by Balin and shin arriving on howless
shin has a white one with balen having a
black one and this likely represents the
norsemit Wolves of Darkness and Light a
huge announce to Aaron s Bailey on
Twitter for pawning out the similarities
between Shin and Joan of Arc looking at
them side by side I think you can
definitely see how they line up and it
was a comparison that I hadn't seen
brought up before now the belts all
Satine with their namesakes and both
their surname Sonata Hadi and skull from
Norse mythology one of these wolves
chase the sun whilst the other chased
the moon and on each character's belt we
can either see a sun or moon symbol now
this whole scene is kind of like the
Walks from Lord of the Rings with it
devolving into a big chase scene they
end up circling the wagons and this is
an old west technique to close people in
elsewhere thrawn uses the night sisters
to locate Ahsoka and I love how when
Ahsoka says I see her they see where she
is they literally triangulate her
position using the balls again from last
week which are slowly becoming their
source of weapons all three have to be
in tune to use this and it's kind of
like how the sisters of Fate used to
pass around and share an eyeball also
yeah I think that might be space
Plankton feeding on the space whales you
can you can see a bit of space Plankton
there the ability to see is symbolized
in Ahsoka with her reaching out directly
to zippine through using the force this
is similar to how Luke reached out to
Leia at the end of Empire but
unfortunately it confirms her location
and Enoch's ordered a fire back with the
herd we see as they spot bailin and shin
with the former ordering as Padawan to
kill them he clearly has a different
path he has to follow and he points her
in the direction of the Empire so she
can go off on her own a he should add to
Star Wars only on Twitter for pawning
out that earlier in the season Balin
plays the star map in place you can
actually see aurabesh writing on his
wrist this is the main language in Star
Wars and when translated actually has
some names on it these are Luke Leia Han
Chewie R2D2 C3PO and lastly Ben man's
clearly a fan of the original trilogy
and a I don't bloody blame him now over
the week There's Been lots of theories
about who bailin's really reaching out
to and what the power is that's calling
directly to him Joshua den of nerds did
a big video talking about how this could
be abeloth who was a big bad in The
Legend series fate of the Jedi she's
also part of the ones that appeared in
the Clone Wars and was known as being
the bringer of chaos Mt also did a big
breakdown on the channel about how
peridia links to zepho in which he goes
over all the connections and things you
might have missed this Force attuned Ray
said several tombs spread throughout the
Galaxy that Ino Cordova was
investigating in the Fallen Order series
build with astriums these are similar to
the star map and this of course led the
way directly to paridia now in the game
kalcasters found a tomb dedicated to the
zifonian courgette and this was located
on the planet dathomir this is the same
Planet the Knight sisters took over
after venturing out from their home
Galaxy here it turned out that the
zaponians actually abandon it and this
is when the night sisters took over
empty pointed out the zeppar runes and
symbols which could still be seen on
peridia and these highlighted that the
knight's sisters were deeply linked with
them zepho also had symbols of their
head appearing above the door to the
world Between Worlds so there's
definitely the connection here when you
look deep enough Zephyr lost their way
and descended to the dark side with
kujet wiping out his own people before
venturing out to places unknown in order
to get a fresh start this power could be
what balen's tapping into as I do kind
of feel he's trying to restart the Jedi
Order or rather something better than it
you I train to be something more this
comment makes me think balen's sick of
the constant cycle that he talked about
and thus he wants to restart things away
from the situations that caused the rise
and fall the dark and light side of the
force are constantly at war with one
another with both them going in and out
of balance when discussing shin and
balen Dave filoni said that lightsabers
were a major clue to their intentions
and them being oranges neither a safe
nor a Jedi color it's not the red that
the Sith will but it's not the lighter
color that the Jedi tend to use instead
I think he's creating an order that Taps
into both a dark and light and finally
ends the struggle between the two sides
he Force chokes like a Sith but also
sticks to his word and has Shin rocking
a little Padawan braid let me know your
thoughts below but that's just me going
off in a Big
Time shirts and available but let
me know below if you think baylen's
doing something but between the two baby
anyway balen tells Shin that the
impatience for victory will guarantee
defeat this sort of mirrors the lessons
that Obi-Wan tried to teach Anakin as
his impatience led to the loss of his
limbs the hollers are sent in and the
chase really picks up with Sabine
busting out her Jewel blasters these are
known as westar35s with them possessing
a rapid fire Burst Mode boys thought
they might incorporate them into Ahsoka
having two lightsabers but either way we
have these two characters that like to
do a dual wield also I love how the
naughty cars look like shells themselves
adding to the turtle slash hermit crab
design that they all carry now obviously
there's a lot of similarities to the
Ewoks with the scene last week being
based around one layer met Wicket the
Ewoks had primitive weapons too which we
see the noriosa using in the form of a
slingshot this primitive idea was
something Return of the Jedi used
dramatically and it gave the idea of how
to conquer power and I think they're in
there to really show that you don't need
technology you need the will and the
belief to to take you through through
anything and the fact that you know the
Ewoks were able to defeat the Empire
only using ropes and rocks I think that
said something about them as a race of
creatures
Fighters coming in doesn't matter how
much Machinery you have
if the will of the people is strong
they will always win you failed your
highness
I am a Jedi
like my father before me now Ezra has a
slingshot in Rebels too so who knows
this might even be his elsewhere we see
as the night Troopers allowed under
their ships and these are called lats
which are capable of holding 15 Troopers
in a pilot they do this completely
silently and just have something that
seems slightly off about them now last
week we talked about the rumors
surrounding the Stormtroopers and this
seems to have really taken off without
being lots of Theory videos about them
being Undead Warriors according to the
reports they were resurrected by the
night sisters which is something The
Witches were able to do in both Fallen
order and the Clone Wars and those they
conjured green Mists which resurrected
the dead from pods and caused them to
reanimate and then attack the
protagonists I believe this is similar
to what happened with Marik and though
Marek Fisto theories hit the internet it
seems like he was more just giving us
the idea that the night sisters could do
this looking at the Timeline he didn't
appear until after Balin and shin
rescued Morgan and his armored child
wear and tear like the Troopers have
here now this makes me wonder
Magistrate's Beef goes way back before
season 2 of the Mandalorian as we had
something similar during tales of the
Jedi Ahsoka ended up fighting an
Inquisitor on that and upon killing them
their masks deflated with some smoke
coming out of it this is a Sim the thing
of what happened upon Merrick's death
and he of course was also seemingly an
Inquisitor the great mothers likely
brought all these Troopers back from the
dead and fixed their armor so that they
could operate in combat the Empire's
biggest issue at the moment is that they
don't really have an army as their old
ways haven't worked out as long-term
plants the Clones provided one but they
ended up getting rid of them and instead
leaned towards going with conscripted
soldiers this meant the loyal followers
who'd fight without questioning orders
were gone and once the Republic took
over again the empire was without an
army as we know the first order
eventually comes to be formed but at the
moment the Imperials haven't got any
Legions I can see why thrawn would turn
to this in order to quickly bump up the
numbers how we've even seen how Gideon's
willing to attended cloning again in
order to achieve his goals a huge
announce to Adam for pointing out this
could be building off the back of the
death Troopers created by Joe Schreiber
as they do kind of align with that it
really ramps up the tension for the
fight and Ezra demonstrators Jedi
ideology by refusing to leave anything
behind in these battles we also see
developed a new fighting style which is
completely relying on the force just
like his blind Master Kanan huge it out
to Tom on the mic again for pointing out
that he says the force is my Ally which
is a quote that comes directly from Yoda
now this Force fighting it's getting a
lot of backlash on Twitter but sabine's
had his lightsaber so he had to do
something this new Galaxy is all about
new things and Star Wars going in New
Direction so it does make sense I
thought about this with the combat too
also there's probably not any kyber
crystals in this galaxy hence Reliance
on developing something else I actually
think that the Knight sisters are
tapping into something similar to The
Fours but the reason that they don't use
weapons like the lightsaber is because
the crystals don't to start here and the
fighting style itself could be seen as
something similar to Terrace Cassie
which was a martial arts style developer
fighters in the Star Wars Universe first
dropped in the PlayStation fighting game
that used its name in the title we've
seen it brought up in stuff like solo
boss kicking was even seen in Return of
the Jedi on the Barger nope well it
wasn't a bad stunt mate wasn't no it
always kills me out whenever Mark
Hamill's asked on this he always says
that he was doing Force kicking also I
don't know who said it last week but
shout out to them for noticing that the
chainmail Ezra has is actually made from
Stormtrooper dog attacks this highlights
just how many of them are actually dead
and why thrawn ended up making the Ally
ship that he did now on the ground we
see balen and Ahsoka encountering each
other once more and I love the build up
to this with her seemingly returning
from the dead to him the Sakura adopts a
samurai pose and it leads to a jewel
whilst shin and as reduced from Force
karate kinda reminds me of the drunken
style and yeah let me know your thoughts
Below on it leading towards Shin I love
her cutting his hair and he's able to
use the force to stop her lightsaber
unfortunately he's knocked back which
leads to Sabine then having a rematch
Ahsoka gets bought some time by the T6
returning and bailing clearly wrestles
with following her or joining what's
calling him in the end he goes towards
that making the battle below a lot
easier for the Allies for a bit they do
get surrounded and we even see sabine's
howl I hiding in one of the pods either
way though Balon has abandoned his
apprentice and this may lead to her
ultimately turning against him also we
see the Strategic mind of thrawn with
him very much playing out the battle
like it's a game of chess Ahsoka arrives
to save the day and ultimately thrawn's
forces are ordered to retreat he's very
much just been sacrificing the pawns
though and didn't really care about the
outcome of it he sees it as a success
which is a major cope but it's given him
time to transfer his cargo if I'm
stating the obvious I think these might
be the bodies of his Legion which the
Knight assist will resurrect and that's
why they are pulled from the catacombs
it might even be dead Knight sisters and
this would give him the power to cause
havoc in the Galaxy guess we'll see but
dead dead dead everyone's dead except
for shin who almost gets taken in a
circle offers to help her though and
she's very much tempting Shin in the
same way as Seth would tempted Jedi to
turn anyway we end with Sabine saying I
thought you were dead and it sounds like
she's been checking out one of our
theories
thought you were dead you thought she
was dead
now the naughty can be the sigh of
relief and some famous last words from
Ezra who thinks that he is gonna be
going home we'll say mate because that's
what people normally say before they die
but either way that wraps up the episode
and for the next part of the video I
want to talk about the rumors around the
finale we are just one week away and you
might end up spoiling the show for
yourself if it turns out to be true so
turn off now if you don't want to know
I'll forgive you yeah I'll forgive you
for quitting the video earlier mate I
promise no hard feelings just just do
what you want
what a man come on a heavy
spoilers and you don't want stuff
spoiled anyway we apparently get thrown
returning to the main Galaxy during the
midpoint of the entry he ends up coming
out on top and he promises that a
reckoning is coming the rumors also say
that someone will either die or get
stuck in the protein Galaxy though they
don't specify exactly who this is I
actually think going forward for
baloney's Trilogy we're gonna see travel
back and forth between the two becoming
more commonplace and this could open up
new technologies and ways to use the
force but yeah that's the way that I
think things are gonna go with these
galaxies I am really excited for the
finale and as someone who is pretty down
on the series and that was first handful
of episodes this has really won me
around and I feel like it's the series
that's gonna help Star Wars finally
evolve it it's paid a lot of tribute to
the past with stuff like the Anakin
episode but it's also clearly taking the
franchise in a New Direction which is
something we haven't really had with
Star Wars for a long time anyway let me
know your thoughts on the show below
please drop a like on the video and if
you want to support the channel as a
member of this spoiler Society then
please click the join button get early
access to videos every week for example
we launched the Return of the Jedi one
two days early for members yeah if you
want to support the channel get to see
stuff early just click the join button
and it's just 99 cents a month or 99
Pence if you're in the UK have you want
something else to watch we've got that
Return of the Jedi video on screen right
now so definitely head over there right
after this other way huge thank you for
sticking through the video I've been
poor I'll see you next time you take
care yourself come back for the finale
please come back and yeah see you next
week take care peace